Speaker 1: One of the really interesting things
we're seeing over the last week has been this
reversal from much of the Republican Party
about the Ukraine Russia situation.
And early you saw a bunch of right wingers,
including Trump, Tucker Carlson, Tulsi Gabbard,
who claims to be on the left.
But we know she's not sort of defend Vladimir
Putin, and that did not go super well.
A lot of Republicans just weren't buying it
because it's completely implausible that we
should be supporting Vladimir Putin.
So now they're sort of switching to supporting
Ukraine.
And one aspect of this is that now many people
who have been against Naito for a while are
switching to talk about how great Naito is.
And the sort of most notable bullet point
about this is that Donald Trump is now taking
credit for NATO's existence, even though for
much of his presidency, he wanted to end Naito
and get the U.S. out of it and just completely
take it apart.
Rolling Stone Rolling Stone's Peter Wade has
a good piece of this called the Trump who
wanted to withdraw the U.S. from Naito now
claims credit for its existence.
There would be no Naito if I didn't act strongly
and swiftly.
The former president said he put out this
statement or, you know, it was put out from
by his new spokes, relatively new spokeswoman
Liz Harrington.
He put this out yesterday, and the statement
reads, I hope everyone is able to remember
that it was me.
I mean, it's literally like a little kid.
It was me as president of the United States
that got delinquent Naito members to start
paying their dues, which amounted to hundreds
of billions of dollars.
There would be no Naito if I didn't act strongly
and swiftly, which is a laughable claim.
Naito was very strongly in existence before
Trump became president.
There was no sign Naito was going away.
Trump adding Also, I mean, he.
Trump did everything good, I guess, guys.
Also, it was me that got Ukraine, the very
effective anti-tank buster javelins when the
previous administration was sending blankets,
let history.
So note now, of course, revisionist history
is not unusual when it comes to Donald Trump.
And you need only go back to an article.
I mean, in this case from January of 2019
from Vanity Fair by Eric Lutz, which reported
that Donald Trump privately discussed destroying
the Naito alliance.
The president repeatedly told aides that he
wanted to withdraw the United States from
the alliance.
The New York Times reports Trump has long
criticized Naito frequently bellyaching that
the military partnership has been unfair to
the U.S. and on and on and on.
However, it appears Trump's attacks on Naito
are more than bluster, citing senior administration
officials, the New York Times reported late
Monday.
Again, this is January 2019 that at several
points in 2018, Trump discussed withdrawing
the U.S. from the international organization,
a move that would effectively doom the 29
nation alliance and empower Russia, which
has spent years seeking to weaken it.
So understand the absurdity of this.
Trump now is taking credit for Naito because
Naito is so involved in supporting Ukraine
against Russia.
What Trump actually was threatening and thinking
of threatening to do and thinking about doing
during his presidency was pulling out of Naito
altogether, which would have crippled it.
And of course, his people will praise the
flip flop as the absolute truth and say everybody
else is brainwashed.
If you don't accept Trump's lies now, remember
that this is a common thing that Donald Trump
does.
He told people originally that the vaccine
is something he created and gets credit for
it.
And of course, that's not true.
Then he played coy with anti-vax, talking
about freedom and all these different things.
And then his supporters didn't get the vaccine,
and then he flipped again and says, Well,
I get credit for it and his supporters.
They do both.
They they they see.
Or maybe they don't accept the absurd contrast
and contradiction in Trump's claims about
vaccines.
And yet they don't care.
They still support the guy, and it's very
similar when it comes to Naito, and it's really
important to understand the degree to which
this guy is a liar and so are his followers.
Not only did Trump constantly attack Naito,
which aligns him with Putin, remember, Putin
is one of the big antagonists of Naito.
And when Trump was president, he aligned himself
with the antagonists of Naito.
Remember that Trump also froze U.S. aid to
Ukraine?
I mean, remember the entire Ukraine thing,
the impeachment and everything?
Trump wanted dirt on Biden from Ukraine, and
he initially said, We're not giving them the
the aid until they get me the dirt now.
Eventually, pressure became so great that
Trump did have to release that military aid,
and now he wants us to believe he's always
been the big defender of Naito.
And it's actually thanks to him that Naito
even exists.
We all see through it, but unfortunately many
of his followers don't.
And that's what I want to talk about next.